in a good mood because of this next
guest i don't like to say that often we
have a very tough love relationship but
she's the co-host of outnumbered a show
i'll be appearing on next friday so
congratulations in advance to them on
the huge ratings bump uh she's also the
host of crimes that changed america and
of course hero dogs you know her and
lover as the human happy hour
uh emily compagno is in the house hello
the human happy hour until my dark heart
shines through it's common it usually
takes two minutes into this interview
before i get called a fat f
i wish we should do like a dramatic
reading of my text messages there's so
one where is that hallmark movie
hallmark presents the fat slob
christmas tale to warm the heart so when
last we met we were at the christmas
tree relighting which
nobody throws a better relighting than
fox news
i haven't been the many christmas tree
lightings in my day but as they go that
would have to be the best one though no
i haven't been part of a better sequel
since godfather 2 when i was an extra in
the back
i'll say this did you get my text my
non-shouting text what's hysterical to
me is how you and i for the rest of our
lives we think that we are like
we should you know we're the help here
yeah yeah which we are and that's a good
thing but we also belong here and so i
learned after the fact that as you and i
were in the crowd watching which was an
awesome place to be we were actually
supposed to be on stage we were supposed
to be on stage with all the other fox
news talent in the background of the tv
show when they're relighting the tree
but me and emily were sitting there
uh just like next to the hot dog guy
like i actually served three hot dogs
and sold one guy a hot pretzel literally
we are so criminally regular but the
other thing i love about you is uh you
left that feel good event which was a
feel-good event in fact the christmas
tree
it was such a good lighting that i've
already promised myself i'm going to go
to next week's relighting i'm going to
be there as well well if you light the
tree on fire to ensure there's a third
yeah you will be let out there'll be
it's no problem there's nobody across
the street after yeah we're going to get
there but you left this feel-good event
and went to another event involving law
enforcement did you not yes i had the
honor of co-hosting the detective rafael
ramos foundation's winter gala
fundraiser alongside our dear friends
dean kane frank siller of tunnel to
towers taya kyle our own amy freeze from
weather and jw cortez and that
foundation if you remember i'm sure you
do
on december 20th of 2014 nypd detective
rafael ramos was assassinated along with
his partner detective wenjin liu just
because they were police officers and
raphael ramos's wife maritza started
this foundation to help the families of
those nypd officers that were lost in
the line of duty and since then it has
just become an incredible foundation
serving so many needs in the law
enforcement community and the actual
community because you and i talk about
all the time they're one and the same
and so the winter gala was last night so
we were all there bringing uh highlight
and and donations and funding to this
incredible foundation so everyone can
learn more at
theremostfoundation.org that's that's
really awesome i love that you do that
stuff uh but before we get too high and
mighty uh with all of your moral
excellence let's not discount the fact
that there was definitely an open bar
[Laughter]
emily does i've gone to a few of these
fundraisers no no you're the most
benevolent soul i know and long before
we were friends i was taken from afar by
all of the good things you do do you
remember when you used to come on the
show and you're like i just brought
meatballs to the firehouse yes yes and i
only had water last night i know you
think i'm some sloppy drunk but everyone
listening you guys i am actually normal
i'm actually well behaved yes i'm
reasonable
yes that means she was crushing pills
but stick with i kid i kid we're just
starting we're just starting trouble uh
but the point is uh no you do a a wonder
of charitable contributions to the
universe and i do commend you for that
it's not often we convened each other on
anything so for that you get that that's
it the only time you're nice to an
officer is when you're trying to get out
of the arrest
it helps to be nice to them 365 days out
of the year all right so you want to
know why i'm really being so nice
because i'm getting a new car right um
yeah yeah i'll tell you the whole story
but uh the dealership i was dealing with
uh they happen to be some fox news super
fans and uh i might owe you a steak
dinner because one of them loved you so
much but uh in the interest of full
disclosure he was like and i as women i
hate that you go through this but he was
like hit me out dude am i am i like
meeting someone for dinner in a couple
hours not cool and that knocked off a
thousand dollars for a sticker price but
he was like is she really amazing in
person as she is on tv
he did that whole thing did you were you
like no she's a drunk oh i didn't say
that i just said no i was like i didn't
say you were drunk i just said no you're
the one but yeah no you got a shot if
you want to move some fords uh over in
staten island we'll work it out i am a
ford girl and also it helps us both if
you tell everyone that i'm awesome so
please
i have done
so much more in the universe than your
agents have in the way of you
just just by associating with you i kid
um but let's talk about this because
something you had alluded to and this is
fascinating we're gonna have a really
quick run of discussion the guy who
burnt down the christmas tree okay no
nobody knows this he was in the 48th
street subway last night one of the
security guards here i will not put him
on route okay so you might have saw the
pictures too yeah when we were all
leaving the building he was showing us
the pictures he's like by the way he's
right outside yeah he was in front of
mcdonald's yeah nobody in like the media
ran with that i thought that was worth
reporting that the guy who burnt down
the tree was at the tree lighting
watching it from across the street he
had front row seats hit better seats
than us there is no greater irony right
now meanwhile he also do you hear about
what he did at the glen maxwell trial no
i heard that oh he might have exposed
himself to glenn maxwell what do you
mean he might have he did expose himself
yeah i know it's your everyday friday
night activity but this guy did it
during the day in front of a federal
courthouse downtown while shouting some
pretty crazy things uh and then came
uptown or midtown where we are now to
watch the christmas tree relenting and i
don't know like surveying his handiwork
like plotting the takedown part too so
you may not have to be the one to burn
down the tree again because this guy's
just gonna do it again this is insane
yeah nobody gets locked up anymore if
you just joined us emily compagno is in
studio the only person getting locked up
actually i'm on board with this is jesse
smallat what a dirtbag i get really mad
about that one because when like there's
a thing man no one's even talking about
this when you fake a racial hate crime
you actually really make it infinitely
harder for the next person who's
involved in a racial hate crime not let
alone a gay person who says they're
being attacked because of their sexual
orientation so for that alone i'm just
really bothered so i thought yesterday
was one of those days where americans
all won because it was the system doing
its job and it was the facts supporting
what we all knew to be a guilty verdict
so i'm glad it kind of played out that
way you yourself as someone who i mean
it i know you have a lot of empathy on
both sides of these debates i mean maybe
not so much for jesse smallette but you
had to feel on some sense uh yesterday
was a day of validation for the system
no i think in part
i also think that it illustrates that in
the prism of our society of which the
the court system is just one component
there's not additional forms of
accountability or justice so yes he was
found guilty and convicted of five out
of the six counts but the media hasn't
apologized yet no the elected officials
in very high positions like our
president like our vice president who
rushed to judgment and have used that as
a narrative to attack
hard-working good americans who haven't
broken the law they haven't said oh we
were wrong they haven't said why is it
that i rush to judgment in certain cases
proclaim something to the heavens and in
others tell everyone to wait for the end
wait for the jury to decide wait for it
to be tried why aren't our elected
officials saying we believe in the
system and we support our juries think
about that i mean you make it you make
it a really great point because to the
to the jesse smallitt situation we
played a montage earlier of multiple
media entities in the immediate
aftermath of his story breaking saying
you can't even question this it is
offensive to me as a black woman it's
offensive to me as a person uh with no
facts in hand yet we're sitting here
weeks removed from a guy in waukesha
wisconsin running over 45 white people
that he professed to kill on facebook
and we're like well we don't know what
the deal was yet and it just drives me
crazy because there is this rush to
judgment to assume racism and the worst
of intent on one side of the country and
i just think it's so toxic for the
entirety of the country but my question
for you
is in this situation do guys usually
serve time for this kind of crime or is
he just going to get big probation no so
the precedent there in illinois the
prior conviction for this which was sort
of a funny story which was a guy in 2011
i want to say who
faked that he was attacked and robbed of
his oprah tickets because he was too
embarrassed to tell his wife that he
didn't have over tickets he was
convicted of the same thing disorderly
conduct as we know there in illinois
that that filing a false police report
falls under disorderly conduct and he
was convicted and he served no time so
that's the precedence however here
there's five charges or five convictions
and also there were about you know a
hundred thousand man hours expended
investigating this and so let's see what
the sentencing is i think it would i
think some jail time might be warranted
who knows because apparently here arson
doesn't get you jail time and a lot of
other things so don't expect it and if i
can just make another point about the
legal thing that's what i was trying to
look up um so again about about that
disorderly conduct and about what that
encompasses in massachusetts right now
the former suffolk county d.a who has
now been elevated thanks to vice
president harris's tie-breaking vote uh
under her watch that was a crime that
she decriminalized
automatically was not a crime it also
included in this long list certain theft
certain threats um things that matter
and when you remove discretion when you
remove the ability for a prosecutor or a
judge to say in this case i'm going to
do something different because this
person needs to be locked up this person
needs to be charged when you remove that
that is when the violence happens that
is when judges say my hands are tied and
it goes both ways both in lack of
severity and in severity when someone
says i you know let him come back home
to help earn money for his his family
while he's on her whatever all of those
facts matter because every case is
individual and that is the level of
criminal justice quote reform that we
are seeing that is having these
incredible effects detrimental effects
on society because it's the pendulum has
swung way too far fast
so yes and the point i was making
earlier then you might have backed me up
on this is that we have configured the
system in a way that's demonstrating
more empathy for the perp than the
victim
yeah and that's frustrating oh yeah
i mean and the thing is the system has
baked into it positions that are
advocates for the victim and advocates
for the defendant that's what the public
defender is for that's what attorneys
are for that's what certain protections
in the system so when prosecutors start
acting more like defendant advocates
then it breaks down the system because
all of the positions are there already
it works if you let everyone do their
job if people stop doing their job
that's when they're there are these huge
breaks in the system and you remove that
that discretion on everyone's hands to
be able to say all right this one we're
going to deal with it differently or
this one this one we're going to i love
that a certain way i love how when you
said if people stopped doing their job
you looked right at my staff in the
control booth
good wake it up and i'm kidding i love
you both you guys would start this yeah
just get going i'm kidding if you just
joined us emily compagno is in the
studio we're having a grown-up
conversation about the fact that a lot
of these bail reforms have set the city
on fire the la district attorney who may
well get removed uh if he gets impeached
gascon
wants us to believe that these bail
reforms have played no role in making
the streets more dangerous and i don't
think there's any world where you can
say that with a straight face unless you
really are just concerned with
self-preservation politically and i just
wanted to make this additional point
before you respond it was in
philadelphia that their d.a said we
don't have a crime problem we've but
we've heard two district attorneys
downplay the significance of an increase
in homicides like when someone says to
me oh but aside from the homicides it's
fine like homicide's pretty bad last
they checked no
chi sabudin district attorney in san
francisco same thing blamed the actual
rank and file said if they would do
their job then i can do mine in addition
to a whole host of other hideous
comments and concepts that have been
filtering through his office which is
why a lot of da's have resigned under
his watch and he too
is up for um
impeachment recall thank you recall
in june so
yes it's horrifying these are examples
where people elected i think in good
faith who they thought would take a
compassionate approach to prosecution
and prosecutions deserve a compassionate
approach and instead they got these
weird robots
self-aggrandizing refusing to see the
statistics and refusing to
compassionately view
all of the victims
retail otherwise i mean of course
homicides that should go without saying
in all of the assaults and the
recidivist behavior that's resulting in
all of these like middle aged and
elderly getting attacked and whatnot but
employees who are being punched and
pepper sprayed and killed protecting
rita i mean the the amount the spectrum
is mind-boggling and these guys refuse
to acknowledge it and they blame the
people who are working the hardest to do
so i mean i think the comments as well
like on you brought up uh
when pressed about the la sheriff's
president or the sheriff himself who was
basically who pointed out your point
like whoa this is happening under your
watch you have to do something he goes
well it's as my dad told me you don't
wrestle with a pig so instead of having
alliances and support between all of
these different players in the system we
are having an antagonistic attacking
relationship between the prosecutor who
should be close and an ally of the
sheriff calling him a pig
who that is an elected official and it's
showing such an indifference to the
people this is affected by totally so
we're going to fight each other instead
of the real problem is what happens and
this is where i i you know i say this to
everybody listening of all political
persuasions we're all being failed in
this situation these i'm not a
republican making this point i'm just an
american who wants to walk around on
safer streets and we can't do that right
now new york is a mess right now you
know someone was talking to me earlier
about christmas caroling i was like yeah
nobody goes christmas caroling in 2021
first of all nobody answers their door
anymore you knocked on somebody's door
to sing christmas cows dead on answering
are they the only caroline happening in
the city is the screaming of people
running on the street being chased by
some guy with a knife it's someone
calling 911 shouting there's an arsonist
on the front porch get out of here with
that caroling that's the christmas carol
accounts i know but that's that's why we
can't have nice things and people don't
understand it emma i say that all the
time about the walking tours i'm like
yeah we still have walking tours they're
now just called running tours you know
but it's like it's terrible and we only
laugh because it's like a coping
mechanism because we live here and like
de blasio's like ah it's the safest big
city in the world but i i'm so sick of
the comparison of yeah it's less murders
than it was in the 70s but that doesn't
make the 70s the standard of living we
want you know and then when the
philadelphia district attorney is flat
out saying oh we don't have a crime
problem in our town they just broke
their murder record that's a problem but
nobody wants to own that so maybe we
should go christmas caroling to own to
lower the temperature how's your chris
can you how's your singing game these
days with all the booze and you do
i have the worst voice on the planet i'm
like super musical but i have a horrible
singing voice i can't wait i can't
imagine i'd enjoy it any less than
you're conversational i kid i owed you
one i've been too nice on this interview
it's been two do you remember the intro
i'm sorry has it been too long
i said you were like wonderful but you
call me names via text that's fine um
quick last point about what you brought
up about philadelphia and the murder
rate and all that stuff it's the the
underserved the black and brown
communities who are shouting the loudest
and being stamped out by the progressive
lefts who are coming in performatively
and like with the savior mentality and
are ignoring them because the the
heartbreaking interviews coming out of
philadelphia saying
what is he talking about this is my
family my fiance my kids that are
getting murdered he's not listening to
those voices and those voices are who he
swore to represent so to me that's the
largest tragedy of all and this is why
we can't have nice things it's
unbelievable you make a lot of great
points today i'm proud of you i know i'm
amazing now listen the bar was low
coming in but if even if the bar was
medium you would have cleared it so for
that
the second tragedy is me having to look
at your face
merry christmas
you're annoying
get around get her out of here